(Lively Techno Music)
- What up?
It's your boy C-Czar
Well, ribbit, blah,
blah, blah, blah
it's Prince Charming
I'm 17 years old
My catch phrase is
"let them eat cake!"
- [Female] Do you eat a lot
out of vending machines?
- I love candy for
dinner, what about you?
Let them eat cake!
That's my catch phrase!
So, like, whatever
the question was,
it's like slit my neck.
- Don't ...
- I'm good on ice, but
I'm also good in bed.
(sexual noises)
Yo', you're my son, son!
- Ooh
- Let them eat cake!
Blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah
I will straight up drop
a bullet in your unit!
Blah, blah, blah, blah
But like being
with you, it's like
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah
but it's also like blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah
And I'm straight up
having the time of my life
(Lively Techno Music)